you ever gamble yes yes yes did you ever
good at being moderate with that I don't
know why there's only one one person you
know with a fat stack and they're
gambling like they just have no concept
of what money means right right and it's
kind of inspiring a little bit yeah so
he puts like literally a thousand
dollars and on this little black icon
yeah so I'm like I gotta ride with this
guy yeah yeah I can't let him bet his
whole stack alone right I'm pushing up
there probably 150 bucks great great I'm
riding with you let's go and then
someone else is like oh
yeah the boys are the boys are on black
okay
some girls like it's my birthday and she
puts his [__] up it's like it's her
[__] okay we cannot lose spins the
ball we're all looking at it like this
is gonna be just like this is gonna be
great
wow and it hits red
and now you guys are all like well I
guess we're all friends at least yeah
exactly yeah